Brian Davis 19th century American slave
revolts shaped the communities of
descendants of American slaves tonight
and Sunday the Pulitzer prize-winning
author speaks about his book in Human
Bondage slave rebellion and its impact
on America tonight at 10:00 p.m. Eastern
and tomorrow at 4:00 p.m. Eastern on
book TV we are here with Olga Carmen
author of scatter my ashes over Havana
what is your book about it's my life
it's a story of a girl who lives in
Havana and has American dreams
especially when she's a teenager
she was under the influence of American
movies especially the love stories which
always ended happily musicals westerns
also comic books true romances also
music this was the age of rock and roll
and there were stations in Havana that
played mostly American music so we love
that and I wanted more than anything to
have a chance to visit the United States
so why did you come to the Y and so I
visited the United States and the
opportunity came when I was fifteen to
spend a year at a place called Scarsdale
New York and live there in a house with
a family and go to high school for a
year and I thought you know the skies
had opened as it turned out it was a
very difficult experience because I was
not prepared for the cold and and it was
we have to walk to school about a mile
in the snow and it was traumatic to say
the least but my American dream came
true and that's I met the man I would
marry five years later I met him when I
was fifteen and five years later I came
back to the United States and with my
trousseau
in my suitcase so the story is about
that it's also about my Cuban dreams
because as I was growing up when I was a
teenager those were the years of the
Cuban Revolution and I was very much
a supporter of Fidel Castro and of the
Revolution I was very idealistic as most
18 17 18 year old persons are and I
thought that he would bring us social
justice decency and a new Cuba so I had
high hopes for the revolution so those
were my dreams describe the political
situation during that time here very
exciting and very awful you know I
remember during the early teens was
during the dictatorship of a very
corrupt the usual corrupt military
dictator in Latin America his name was
Batista what made a difference was that
we had a man who was ready to stand up
against him this man was Fidel Castro
and so while I was in high school for
example my boyfriend was selling
Revolutionary bonds to support the
revolution while at the same time I had
a classmate whose father was a general
in the Batista government and one day he
gave us a ride home and we have to put
our legs up because on the floor it was
machine guns all the way door-to-door on
the floor of the car so I was very much
aware uh you know the political turmoil
in Cuba and then when the revolution
came to power in January 1 1959 I stood
up put my hand to my heart and sang the
Cuban national anthem describe your
flight from Cuba amid all of this
political turmoil things began to change
as I understood it very fast I it was
obvious to me within maybe 2 or 3 months
that we were losing our freedoms day by
day and that this was going to be a
totalitarian government and my friends
were leaving Havana was a city by the
time I left in 1960 only two years after
the Revolution came to power by that
time you couldn't find a suitcase in
Havana which is you know I bought the
last cardboard suitcases left and
and I left under different circumstances
because I left to get married I'm my
left by ship which was pretty rare and
the reason was that I had my true self
in my suitcase and and that and so I
left following a romantic dream but I
also left after my Cuban dream and died
describe what it was like to lose your
freedom day by day well for one thing
when you picked up the phone you heard a
click and you knew your conversation was
being taped for another thing very early
on there were committees for the defense
of the revolution formed in every block
which meant for example that neighbors
who had maybe taught you ballet lessons
were now looking to see whether any
strangers came to your house people cars
they didn't know they were standing on
their porches looking at your house and
meant that in my own house I couldn't
speak in front of my mother
because my mother was an ardent
revolutionary and okay I hate to admit
this in a way I was afraid I was afraid
I don't think she would put me in jail
but I I don't know what I was afraid of
but I was afraid
we spoke very little it broke the family
it separated us for political reasons I
saw businesses closing overnight
especially the newspapers I have to tell
you Buffalo has one newspaper when
Castro came to power Cuba and I had I
think